well after 11 days of fighting like that
there is a ceasefire between israel and
terrorist organization hamas
president biden is said to react to the
news at the white house while that
situation is cooled down for now
the conflict over the fighting in the
middle east is heating up in america
new video shows a shocking attack on
jewish diners
by what witnesses say is a
pro-palestinian mob
[Applause]
so dana we've been watching this play
out in the middle east 4 000 rockets
fired by hamas
at israeli civilian targets over the
last 11 days but it's boiled
over into the states and we've seen jews
hunted down in the streets
by what people are saying are
pro-palestinian protesters i would call
them
more than that but that's what we're
seeing on the videos right so and being
investigated as a potential hate crime
also
there are some because of social media
or new technology there are ways
that these groups can organize and say
you know meet up this is where we're
going to be
and uh there should possibly that will
lead police to be able to one either
protect the people that are out and
about
or at least track down perpetrators of
this another piece of this as joe biden
gets ready to make a statement in about
25 minutes
um first of all i don't understand how
hamas has conditions
for a ceasefire right and i
understand that the protection of life
is very important but we also have to be
very clear-eyed about the root cause
of who supports hamas and what hamas has
done
even to the people of gaza um putting
these
missile targets right there in the
middle of hospitals and schools
and the propaganda that the
hamas is able to get out of this is that
they are
strong that they are the position in the
position of being
the the big guy the one that can save
everybody when actually they're putting
so many people in danger last thing on
this that there's just not enough
attention i don't believe katie
on the fact that the democrats in
congress some democrats in congress
are trying to put a halt to a recently
approved
weapons sale from the united states to
israel
this has been they're kind of pro forma
these things are almost always
put forward and agreed to all of a
sudden that is in jeopardy
and it's like that those democrats that
are calling for that are watching right
there on their screen they can see
that israel has utilized that money well
you can see it the iron dome is
protecting innocent people
and the democrats somehow think that
there should be less of that
i think we should pay a little bit more
attention to that before joe biden gets
to the podium in about 25 minutes
yeah well and what about that we've seen
the squad saying that they don't want to
replenish the iron dome but you can
argue that the iron dome
actually saves the lives of people in
gaza because it gives the israelis a
buffer
not to react with full military
operations every time hamas the
terrorist organization
fires a rocket at civilian targets
yeah i don't i i don't think there's any
question here that
israel is the far superior military
power they're also a far superior
economic power katy
but you know to my mind i think what's
going on here
is there's been a tremendous shift in
public
attitudes here in the united states that
kind of violence that we showed earlier
is to be condemned it's reprehensible
luckily i haven't heard about this being
any kind of widespread phenomenon here
in this country
but what is true is that we live and i
think dana mentioned this in an age of
social media this is the first time
we've really had
israeli palestinian conflict in this you
know kind of social media milieu and so
a lot of voices that were previously
ignored are now
being heard and i think a lot of those
voices no longer you know for most of my
life
israel israel was a vulnerable state
and uh you know one that the united
states viewed as an ally to be supported
uh and now israel is a powerhouse in
that region
uh we make deals with them in terms of
taking on the iranians and the like
and i think there are lots of people who
are questioning how they're using their
power
at this moment that's why i think
worldwide opinion
is going in the other direction and a
bernie sanders
a jewish u.s senator is leading the
drive
to take away the money for further
military weaponry
kennedy if you're going to take uh money
away from anyone
in terms of selling weapons take it away
from saudi arabia
that that is the most concerning to me
absolutely uh
hamas is a terror organization so the
question is you know do you stand for
freedom or do you stand for marxism
because marxism
they they embrace and love uh hamas
and and they're defending palestinians
and they're rationalizing
terroristic violence israel is a lone
democracy
in the middle east and it is our ally
because they stand for freedom
and and that is the big goal in our
society and across the world right now
what do you stand for do you stand for
marxism or do you stand for freedom
uh it's it's that cut and dry and i hope
that we have a president
who is able to handle this
diplomatically i don't have a lot of
faith in him but i do support him
and i hope he brings peace
jesse last word to you well juan said
worldwide opinion has shifted against
israel i never knew worldwide opinion
was ever with israel
that's news to me and let's all remember
why they're there
it's because of the holocaust millions
were slaughtered
in germany and they were put there by
the british because that was a british
territory
and harry truman a democrat was the
first to recognize
the israeli country there and since it's
founding they've been fighting to the
death trying to survive
being attacked from all sides and
they're fighting a terrorist
organization this terrorist organization
they are not trying to avoid
civilian casualties israel is trying to
avoid them
hamas is not trying to avoid them so if
if you're living in long island
and manhattan is just shelling you
indiscriminately with rockets all day
and the world is calling for restraint
while the
insurgents are hiding in hospitals and
schools here in manhattan
you do your best to avoid civilian
casualties but you're going to take
those people out
as surgically as you can to save your
own people
and to make peace and that's what the
israelis are doing
all right we'll see if the ceasefire
holds hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else